-Hello, everyone, and welcome
back to the attic.
Last week you may recall
we addressed speculation
about the sudden disappearance
of my copy of "The Thorn Birds,"
the 1977 Australian romance
novel that inspired
the hit 1983 miniseries
starring a frequently shirtless
Richard Chamberlain.
In 1983, it turns out that was
the exact right amount
of chest hair for a leading man.
Chamberlain never would have
survived in these hairless times
we're living in, where our
sex symbols are all Chrises
with chests smooth enough
to eat off.
Anyway, the point is, I left
the window open overnight
to get rid of the wasps,
but then "The Thorn Birds"
flew out, we think,
because it's mating season.
But as you can see,
Thorny is back
and maybe with child?
Impossible to tell.
Meanwhile, the president is
pregnant with rage --
that's a segue, a bad one,
but technically still a segue --
and decided to give up
in the fight against coronavirus
in order to reopen the economy.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
You would think that
putting aside his venality,
his narcissism,
and his deadly incompetence,
Donald Trump could
at the very least muster
a little empathy for the victims
of this pandemic,
their loved ones,
and the millions
who have
put themselves in harm's way,
lost jobs, or made tremendous
personal sacrifices
during this crisis.
But of course,
he can't do that,
because he's incapable
of empathy.
He only has two emotions --
boredom and rage.
He's either staring off
into the distance
while someone talks
about complex policy details
or hissing at reporters
like a snake
whose nest was just disturbed.
In fact, just listen to
the cold, detached way in which
Trump talked about allowing
Americans to die
in order to reopen the economy
and the 30 million people
who have lost jobs
because of his handling
of this crisis
during an interview on ABC
yesterday.
-Do you believe that's
the reality we're facing?
That lives will be lost to
reopen the country?
-It's possible there will be
some, because you won't be
locked into an apartment
or a house or whatever it is.
-There are 30 million
Americans who are unemployed.
You don't need me
to tell you that.
We're expecting the new
unemployment rate this week.
There have been forecasts,
15, 16, 17%.
One of your advisers projected
an unemployment rate of 19%.
That's nearly one in five
Americans without a job.
How bad is this going to get?
-Well, that is what it is.
-Wow. What soaring words.
It reminds me of
Martin Luther King's
"I slept pretty good
last night" speech.
Or FDR's famous response
when they told him
about Pearl Harbor --
"Well, [bleep] happens."
Usually when someone is that
soulless and dead-eyed,
you're not asking them questions
about the economy,
you're holding up
a Rorschach test.
"And what is this, Donald?"
[ As Trump ]
"It is what it is.
"Very, very interesting.
Okay, guards,
you can put him back
in his restraints now."
"Oh, I don't think the guards
can hear you."
"Donald, what have you done?"
Yesterday Trump also made his
first major trip in months
to tour a Honeywell factory in
Arizona, a trip that gave us
what may end up as one of the
enduring images of this crisis.
Trump toured a mask factory
as his White House signaled
they were basically
just giving up
on suppressing
the coronavirus pandemic
to focus on reopening
the economy instead.
And has he was doing that,
someone chose to blast
"Live and Let Die"
on the speakers.
-The material traps
the particulates.
-♪ Live and let die ♪
♪♪
-Wow.
Welcome to the resistance,
Honeywell factory floor
deejay?
Doesn't get much more
on the nose than that.
What were the other songs on
that play list?
-♪ It's the end of the world
as we know it ♪
♪ It's the end of the world
-You can hear all those
classic hits and more
on "Now That's What I Call
Symbolism."
"Live and Let Die" playing while
Trump tours a mask factory
during a pandemic
is the surest sign yet
that we're living
in a video game.
And if we are in a video game,
does anyone have the cheat code
to get rid of wasps?
Because I tried up, up, down,
down, left, right, left, right,
B, A, start, and that just
made them angrier.
Anyway, sure enough,
during that same trip,
Trump brushed off the
growing death toll
and said he was eager
to force Americans
back to work prematurely,
telling them to think of
themselves as participants
in an armed conflict.
-And you see what's going on.
They have to open.
And the people of our country
should think of themselves
as warriors.
Our country has to open.
I'm viewing our great citizens
of this country
to a certain extent and to
a large extent as warriors.
They're warriors.
We can't keep our country
closed.
We have to open our country.
The people of our country
are warriors.
And I'm looking at it.
I'm not saying anything
is perfect.
And yes, will some people
be affected? Yes.
Will some people be affected
badly? Yes.
But we have to get
our country open,
and we have to get it open
soon.
And I said it before
and I'll say it again.
The people of our country
are warriors.
-That's right, Trump wants
you -- you to be a warrior
while he sits safely in
isolation in the White House.
"I would join in, but I feel
another bone spur coming on,
which is devastating to me,
because the last one happened
right before the Vietnam War.
I mean, what are the chances
that it happens again now?
I mean --"
This is truly sadistic.
The president is telling you
to go out and face off
against a deadly virus all for
the sake of the stock market.
The only way that could be more
out of touch is if he said it
while dousing himself in Purell
and holding a 36-pack
of toilet paper.
Every day it seems we pass
a grim new milestone
in the coronavirus pandemic,
with more than 70,000 Americans
now dead and at least
30 million out of work,
which, according to Trump
means it's a perfect time
to stand down
and wrap things up.
-We can't keep our country
closed for the next five years.
You know, you could say there
might be a recurrence,
and there might be.
And, you know, most doctors,
or some doctors say
that it will happen.
And it will be a flame and we're
going to put the flame out.
We've learned a lot, you know.
We've learned a lot about
the coronavirus.
-First of all, who's "we"?
You haven't learned anything.
Whenever the doctors
are up there talking,
you do that thing
where you zone out
and sway back
and forth like a drunk guy
who's trying to pretend
he's sober.
And then you get back up to the
podium having only heard, like,
three words and try to sound
like you know what's going on.
"So what I'm hearing is -- what
I grasped when the scientists
were talking, is that powerful
lights will cure the coronavirus
and give you superpowers.
You know, I saw that
in a documentary once.
Only down -- turns you green.
That's the downside side effect.
So still --
still pretty promising news."
You are incapable of learning.
You showed up to the CDC
in Atlanta surrounded by
some of the best doctors
in the world and all you did
was hold up a printout
of a virus like a kid
who forgot to do his science
project until the last minute.
"As you can see here, the virus
is called Wikipedia.
Side effects include further
reading and external links."
Although actually I will
give Trump credit.
In the span of two months, he
did at least learn one thing --
the name of the virus.
-So you can't put them down
in the, uh, in the category
of the overall population in
terms of this, uh, corona flu.
-Yes, corona flu.
Remember when a deadly virus
was racing across the globe
and the president was getting
intelligence reports about it,
and he got the name wrong,
like the worst member
of your bar trivia team?
"This English rock band is led
by front man Mick Jagger."
"Oh, I know,
it's The Rolling Scones.
Rolling -- In America they're
called The Rolling Muffins.
That's an extra piece
of trivia."
Second, no one,
and I mean no one,
wants to keep the country
closed for five years.
It hasn't even been closed
for five months
and we're already losing
our minds.
I spend six hours a day
washing my hands,
I wipe down every package like
it's coated in anthrax.
I've watched so much Netflix
that my home page says,
"We have nothing left for you.
Try Hulu?"
And I've inhaled so much Lysol,
my urine smells like lemon zest.
No one wants to live like this.
In fact, we didn't have to.
Lots of other major
developed countries
have successfully suppressed
their outbreaks by acting early,
testing aggressively,
and implementing a system
of isolating cases and tracing
their contacts.
Some never even had to fully
lock down, and others
have already reopened,
like in South Korea,
where they had their
first case on the exact same day
we had ours.
And while here in the U.S.,
almost every day at least 25,000
new coronavirus cases
are identified,
in South Korea,
the rate of new confirmed cases
of coronavirus has slowed down
dramatically in recent weeks
to less than ten a day.
Of course if you pointed
that out to Trump,
he probably wouldn't accept it.
"It's not a fair compar--
South Korea is 13 hours ahead,
so they had a jump on it."
In fact, while we're all stuck
in our homes watching reruns
of "Blue Bloods" at 2:00
in the afternoon,
Korean baseball is already
back playing games,
just without fans.
In fact, ESPN is now airing them
here in the U.S.,
which has introduced us
to some truly incredible
team names, like the
NC Dinos and the SK Wyverns,
which are mythical winged
two-legged dragons
with barbed tails.
Last year they even used
augmented reality
to have a dragon fly into
the stadium and breathe fire.
Our baseball teams need
more mascots like that.
The only mythical creature
we have is, I don't know,
is it like an aardvark?
Like a -- like a hairy aardvark
who loves baseball?
Hmm.
We've been highlighting
success stories like that
from South Korea to Iceland
to New Zealand to Taiwan
because they're out there.
There are lots of countries
with competent governments
that managed to suppress
the outbreak
and allow their societies to
safely return
to some semblance of normalcy.
Trump has repeatedly lied
and claimed that, as he put it,
the cupboards were bare when
he took office three years ago
and that's why he's failed
to fight the virus.
But in a new ABC interview,
Trump was asked
why he didn't do anything
to fix the situation.
-You're three years
into your first term.
-Yeah.
-You're now applying
for the job again.
What did you do when you
became president
to restock those cupboards
that you say were bare?
-Well, I'll be honest, uh,
I have a lot of things
going on.
-No, you don't.
All you do is watch TV,
and whenever your aides let you
out of your straitjacket, tweet.
And when you're not golfing,
you're tweeting about golfing.
Like on Sunday, when you
retweeted a post
from your golf course
in Scotland claiming
they had been named best golf
course in the UK and Ireland
by a European golf magazine.
"So nice to see this
great honor, thank you,
but haven't played golf
in a long time."
First of all, that's not true.
You played golf in March
with members of
the Washington Nationals.
Damn it, Nationals!
You were supposed to be
the feel-good team
everyone could be happy with
over the cheating Astros.
Now, I mean, who are
we supposed root for
when baseball comes back,
the Mets?
I mean, they're the only team
that's doing better
during quarantine.
Pretty sure the last president
they met with
was William Henry Harrison,
and then he died ten days later.
That was the year Mr. Met
caught typhoid.
And now, instead of taking
any responsibility
for the situation, Trump
and his toadies on state TV
are whining that he
hasn't gotten enough credit
for only letting
70,000 Americans die
and 30 million
lose their jobs,
like human beer keg
Jesse Watters
on Fox News this week.
-Can you imagine, Greg,
the media, how they'd sound
if Barack Obama were president
during the pandemic?
It'd go something like this --
"Barack Obama, putting politics
aside and sacrificing,
the key to a successful
reelection,
shut down the economy just
in order to save lives."
That's what it would sound like.
Now, I know the president's
not going to get
great coverage like that,
but the president just wants
fair coverage,
because he never got credit
for winning the election.
They said Russia cheated.
He never got credit
for the economy.
They said it was Barack Obama's.
And he's not getting credit
for anything,
for ventilators,
for flattening the curve.
-My God, you sound like
the whiniest pledge
in Sigma Chi.
"The dean is shutting down
our blackface party,
completely ignoring the fact
it was a fundraiser
to help local cocaine dealers."
The U.S. is the richest and most
powerful country on Earth,
and yet we're also the epicenter
of a deadly outbreak
that has been suppressed
in lots of other countries.
And now the president
wants to send you to war
against the virus for the sake
of the stock market.
But at least when he does
send you to war,
he'll do so with this
soaring battle cry.
-That is what it is.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
Since this crisis started,
we've been asking people
to help City Harvest,
so please continue to give.
More and more New Yorkers
are turning to them
to keep food on their tables.
If you're watching this online,
please hit the donate button.
Stay safe, wash your hands,
we love you.